like you called each other I heard that
you're a Texas girl I am yes
it is Euless that's so crazy yeah I'm
Fort Worth Burleson oh okay yeah yeah so
anyway I always love having a text and
no she's like fine have you been to
Texas yes
we love Texas here wait you're a Dallas
Cowboy cheerleader right I did do that
yeah yeah I did do that look I have a
friend that was the Dallas Cowboy
trailer and years ago and here's my
thing about boy no it's really hard
those girls are still and they don't get
paid that's right no you're truly doing
it for the love of the sport which
confused me all the time so people are
obsessed with your show so for those
that don't know so what's your show
about
um well the show it centers around this
woman named Billy who on paper she seems
to have it all she's a wonderful wife
she's a loving mother she's got two
great kids but she just can't stop
thinking about this one particular man
from her past where she was just wild
and free and and
uh and then he comes back he comes back
into her life and the whole show kind of
measures will she take a bite of this
forbidden fruit oh my gosh yeah well
here's the thing there was a certain
scene with a certain man in a certain
shower and it's and it certainly was
seen around the world and he um this is
the one from her past right yes that's
right and
um it's well he he has gifted
but I'll check it out
[Applause]
playing this kind of sexually charged
character like this role has it like
affected your real life
yes it did you know I think um one of
the biggest themes of this show is you
know it's okay for a woman to have wants
and needs you know it's a very natural
thing and it's also not something that
we're used to necessarily seeing on TV
you know playing this role I mean she is
dynamite in a box she is larger than
life this character yeah and she really
sort of taught me that if I you know
expect my life to look a certain way or
if I have needs and you know that it you
have to have the guts you have to have
the guts to go out there to get the life
that you want and to speak up and to
speak up even if your voice shakes you
just gotta I think the older you get to
you start caring less it's just like I
can't worry about what you think about
me I'm worried about what I think about
me yes like you know I want to like have
pride in myself and my and what I want
to do in my life well it's just when you
start liking yourself actually when you
actually start liking yourself you want
people to treat you correctly so yeah
and you correct them and you correct
them yeah and that's okay that comes
with age so yeah
[Laughter]
we're all in different paths remember
[Music]